[Music]
welcome to session 25 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series this time
we're looking at somebody who's just a
major figure massively influential
Robert Heinlein some people call them
the Dean of science fiction
you know you there's like one Dean out
there these other people talk about him
in terms of the big three with azimoff
and Clark so what we do in these these
these talks I give you a few handouts
and stuff like that we talked a little
bit about biography of the person
Islands case he lived quite a long time
and did a lot of cool stuff and wrote a
lot and then talked about the world the
narrative world that they constructed
and then some of the philosophical
themes his work is very rich I picked up
five main themes that I thought would be
interesting to talk about but we
certainly can talk about many more so
one is a cultural national identity
another is artificial intelligence and
its role like particularly in the moon
is a harsh mistress another is the the
role of the you know sort of individual
relationships we could say personal
relationships family friends partners
and comrades he's also got a lot of
interesting reflections on leadership
and what genuine leadership is and you
know how people are good or bad leaders
and then he's he's really associated
with the libertarian movement in many
respects as a matter of fact this this
edition of the book notice it says his
classic Hugo award-winning novel of
libertarian revolution right and he was
he was connected with the libertarian
party and and and some of the
intellectual movements in interesting
ways will we'll talk about that but I
thought I could frame it in terms of
what living free means because that was
a key idea for him living free but we
could talk about other things how how he
handled it mishandled women in his
stories
you know mankind and space
life-extension there's all sorts of cool
stuff that we can refer to I get into
Heinlein I imagine the way some of you
probably did as well when I was younger
you know reading sci-fi because it's
books were everywhere and you know there
were always a ton of them I didn't
actually read any of the juvenile books
that he wrote that was interesting to
find out about that he wrote this entire
series of sort of like juvenile sci-fi
but I remember going to the Waukesha
library just you know getting a book
after book after book and then you know
when new ones came out when he became
productive again in the 80s that was
there was kind of nice as well
and I do remember one other kind of
funny thing that I'll tell you about
before we like died then a stranger in a
strange land I read that in high school
and I was in an AP combined English and
history the merit in American literature
and American history class which meant
that you know big sections all together
and I got into a big argument with the
teacher in the middle of the class
because I was you know kind of sci-fi
nut as a kid and I thought she was
misinterpreting the book and I don't
remember what we argued about but it was
a big mistake to like argue with the
teacher in front of the class and the
biggest mistake was I was actually right
and she was actually wrong about which
was you know terrible ideas when you're
when you're contradicting an authority
figure and the other teacher like just
came down really hard he kicked me out
of class that day and and I mean I still
don't remember what the argument was
about but it had something to do with
interpretations of the book and I've
read a lot of Heinlein at the time so I
thought I knew it you know better and I
probably did than she did but that was
that was not the way it's working and
you know if I'd read his books a little
more attentively I probably would have
realized that was a losing strategy at
that
you know as a 16 year old to try to try
to argue with the teacher so let's let's
talk first about his biography you
notice that he he lives you know a very
long life born in 1907 dies in 1988
so 71 years old he was unhealthy for
much of his life in one way or another
but he packed a lot in he's a Midwestern
ER well it depends on how how you
classify the Midwest right because
sometimes we think like maybe Missouri
and Kansas and places like that I really
the plains states but they they call
themselves the Midwest and I think in
his time they were probably you know
closer culturally to us here in the the
center of the Midwest here in Wisconsin
so he's born in Missouri and then
eventually they're gonna move to Kansas
City and there's there's not a lot
really going on in his childhood that I
thought I wanted to pack in here given
how much other stuff there is he he goes
to University of Missouri Kansas City
for one year and then he decides and
this is you know you notice in the 1920s
he wants to become a naval officer so he
leaves there and he goes to the u.s.
Naval Academy graduates from there gets
married his first wife first of three
that marriage is only gonna last a year
and he's transferred from from ship to
ship as you know is the case one of the
interesting things he's assigned to one
of the first aircraft carriers and he's
a radio communications guy because he's
just brilliant you know sort of across
the board you can do engineering
and he's not a typical engineer he knows
literature so not only was he assigned
to one of the first aircraft carriers
the guy he was working under ends up
that in World War two getting sort of
bumped up through the ranks and becoming
a really important Admiral so he would
often get interviewed later on about
what's it like to work under under this
guy and but then he gets sick he gets
discharged from the Navy because he
contracts tuberculosis which is kind of
a you know I mean I understand why they
discharged him but that's kind of a sad
way to get your way out and he enrolls
at UCLA for a short time he's gonna
study you know a bunch of different
subjects but he leaves after just a few
weeks and he starts working in politics
he starts working in Upton Sinclair's
campaign the Upton Sinclair doesn't win
and it's kind of interesting because
people try to place based on the novels
and based on a lot of his you know sort
of proclamations where he fits
politically and in some respects he's he
doesn't it makes sense to place him in
the libertarian camp and in some
respects but in other respects he's more
of an anarchist and then sometimes he
looks more like socialists the you know
one thing you can say is that he doesn't
fit neatly into the liberal or
conservative political camps he's got
this this really strong emphasis on
either the common good or the integrity
of the individual and it carries
throughout his his work so he you know
he starts writing stories he actually
runs for the California State Assembly
don't win it's matter of fact he ran for
office a few times never once
but I think it's probably you've
probably learned slowly running for
office right and there's probably a lot
of races if you were going to be running
for office work
maybe you're just doing it sort of like
we have the pirate party here in
Wisconsin I don't know if you guys know
about about that they're never gonna win
anything you know they're they're the
third parties you could possibly get but
you know it's kind of cool that we have
them there to to mix things up a bit and
to say things that the other parties
won't won't say so anyway he starts
writing and he only put down his novels
I didn't put down his collections of
short stories I didn't put down the
short stories because if I did this
would be like a five page document
there's no way I was gonna pack him that
much but he now it's interesting because
he is a pulp writer at first and a lot
of the people that we've looked at in
this series they you know eventually
they transition to novels and that that
could be where the making a living would
be as a writer because some of the pulps
didn't pay well at all some of them
would take her stories and never pay you
it was it was kind of tough way to live
Heinlein is a guy who manages to figure
out how to transition out of the pulp
writing to a more secure writerly
existence and there's there's two main
ways in which he does this one is by
getting Scribner to Commission him to
write all of these these novels were for
kids science fiction novels and that's
incredibly lucrative you know because
you could just keep churning him out and
he it's as if he was writing bad books
but they argue you know geared for for
kids so he's not dealing with as much
stuff he did get in trouble with some
librarians and some newspaper editors
who thought that he was pushing things
to Howard like pushing you know racial
integration or in in one the story there
was a librarian who objected to him
having
divorce court for children where they
could divorce their parents now we call
that emancipation you know so he's a bit
of ahead of his time and he actually
took the time to write back to the
slavery yeah and set him straight about
it
so there's that but then he also figures
out how to do something that none of the
other science fiction writers have done
up to that point that's to get his work
in The Saturday Evening Post because the
sack that that pays a lot better and
that gives you a kind of what would you
call it like cultural yeah the exactly
credibility yeah
because you know if he you know he's you
notice he's like being invited to it's a
world con to speak and stuff like that
that's the science fiction fans and he's
already got them hooked but to get a
much wider audience and they have them
take his ideas seriously he's got to
publish in something you know like like
Saturday Evening Post or you know he
actually you know later on would be in
things like playboy although I think
those are more interviews oh you know
[Music]
yeah I'm taking a look at any of them
but yeah that would be the case remember
the old joke people would say that that
they buy playboy for the articles and
playboy actually did he have like Harlan
Ellison and who else used to write for
them I mean I never believed anybody who
said that people did that sometimes
saying I'm sure some of them were being
truthful about it but so anyway going
back but this he starts writing I should
mention to that so we're skipping back a
little bit during World War two he tries
to reenlist then they won't take him
they say listen you're sick well he
that's one of the reasons why he started
writing professionally he did in the
pension and it was really small and it
was in the depression so you know I mean
having a pension at all in the
depression
already be like a safety net I suppose
right but it wasn't very much so he was
like I get it I gotta get some some
stories out there and start making
something so funny which was I think a
great great motive for doing that as you
say it was long he was an officer I mean
from what he says it wasn't it wasn't
much to live on and you know he was only
in for a short time I don't know how
things work back then well they mean
yeah they mean it wasn't you know in in
service long enough in duty I mean yeah
well you know the the Department of I
think was the War Department back then
didn't have a lot of money to work with
either in the till until the world war
ii started and then suddenly they were
flush you know so i don't know maybe
that played a role it's a good point he
he works in the Naval Air experimental
station doing doing aeronautical
engineering for them and he also a
million yeah yeah as a contractor and he
gets some Isaac Asimov and L Sprague
decamp to work for the Naval Shipyard he
recruits them they're all in
Philadelphia he also meets this Virginia
Ginny gerstenfeld would be the third
wife the you know in between there he
meets as his second wife marries her and
that doesn't actually work out that well
in part because she she becomes a
hardcore alcoholic I don't know the
story behind that but he divorces her
and then you know shortly after the
divorce is final he marries his third
wife Jenny who who would later you know
control his estate they were pretty
inseparable
I guess she was she was very important
in his life and he hands him off said
something kind of interesting he claims
that Heinlein changed his politics
depending on who he was married to
that he allowed his wife whoever it
happened to be to have a very strong
role so that when he was involved with
his second wife he's more of a you know
socialist you know slash liberal you
know and then and then he gets involved
with his other lady and she's she's you
know Republican but she's more
libertarian so he starts going that way
I don't I don't really know I mean
azimoff knew him very well so maybe
there is some some truth to that and you
notice he starts you know just writing
book after book after book after book
and and starts really taking off
he even has one of his books turned into
a movie that wins the Academy Award for
special effects ends up moving to Denver
and they end up you know traveling quite
a bit by the 1950s he takes a stronger
turn towards you know this libertarian
ideology but also he starts supporting
the Republican Party more and part of it
is because of Sputnik you know and the
the Cold War and so these books are from
at that time you know the Starship
Troopers and what was the harsh mistress
and a lot of a lot of his literary
critics see that as an important turning
point for him he sees an ad I don't
remember what the ad was about he was
local paper and he decides that you know
communism is the you know creeping
threat here in the United States we
forms as Patrick Henry League with his
wife and we don't work on goldwater's
presidential campaign later on as well
and you notice there's a few things in
here with his health at different points
we're starting to get sicker and sicker
he's aging too right so he's got a body
that's already compromised he runs into
some problems but he does some cool
things and one of the things I didn't
put in there that I should have put in
in 1969
of course he's interviewed by Walter
Cronkite
he and Arthur Clarke during the moon
landing and giving his sort of
commentary on it that's that's the
statue then that he had as a writer at
that time you notice there's there's a
fallow period in there too from the
mid-70s on until 1980 where he's not
doing that much publishing and writing
and in some respects not doing that well
one critic that I came across had
something really interesting to say
about how we could look at his his works
so this is Gary Westfall and he said
that a lot of people consider that
Heinlein has three periods in his career
he from 39 to 42 he wrote exclusively
for the science fiction magazines with
with Campbell's astounding science
fiction as his venting of choice because
we paid the highest rates then from 45
to 59 while still contributing to
science fiction magazines he focused
most of his energies on breaking into
more lucrative markets and then from 61
to 88 he specialized in as this guy puts
in writing novels that were increasingly
long-winded idiosyncratic and highly
opinionated and the guy says so I
understand why you could have this
interpretation but it doesn't really fit
that well and he proposes a different
and in some respects simpler
interpretation I like this he says I
want to say that there were only two
periods in Hyland's career from 39 to
1957
Heinlein wrote science fiction and from
1958 until his death in 1988 he rose
satires
of science fiction or if that language
seems too strong say that from 30 to 39
to the 57 he took his science fiction
very seriously and after that he no
longer took a science fiction seriously
he started playing around with that so
if that's the case then you know what
would be fitting in there stranger in a
strange land would be kind of
a turning point starts with troopers
would probably fit in there
you know maybe Starship Troopers is a
kind of parody I don't think it is I
think he's he's being serious in writing
it but you look at some of these other
ones like the moon is a harsh mistress
so that's from 60 yeah that's that's
could have been later there's a lot of
funny stuff in here you know a lot of
sort of making fun of the political
situation and a change in influence in
terms of work that he put out well I
mean a lot of the stuff that he's
writing is showing up first in the pulps
and you know he would he would he would
do like what a lot of these these people
that we've looked at there'd be like a
story and then he could expand it what
we call a fix-up
right and it seems like he would you
know he was kind of lucky people wanted
his stuff so he could he could pick
where he wanted to publish it and he
would try to publish it and the stuff
that paid the best which if I ever you
know have that optional I'll do two as
well but as far as the house I don't I
don't think I don't think that makes any
I do know that that he was running into
some problems with Scribner which was
due at the juvenile stuff they weren't
real happy about the other stuff he was
publishing and and certainly he was like
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna bother with
this anymore I'm gonna do other stuff
instead it's a matter of fact so let me
I brought a few interesting things that
I found online
so Heinlein became such an important lot
there I've got this this thing it's a
form letter that one one person who
wrote him actually got that
and it's a form letter that he would use
to answer people sending him stuff you
notice it's got like checkboxes and
they're they're weird some of them are
perfectly rational some of them are
weird stuff so he's like you know
there's a checkbox for my agent handles
all business your letters been sent to
him or don't send books to be autograph
too many have failed to reach me or you
say that you've enjoyed my stories for
years why did you wait until you
disliked what the story before then he's
got other ones where he's like please do
not write me again for legal reasons I
do not read unpublished manuscripts and
then he's gonna ask what your letter was
most welcome loaded with friendliness of
no requests or demands you suggest that
no answer was expected but I must tell
you how much it pleased me I wish you
calm seas following winds and a happy
voyage your like and if you can see the
sort of stuff that he was like I mean
you get a letter then check it off and
say here mail it with this yeah so check
this up the sort of stuff that he's got
it yeah I mean now you could just like
cut and paste right if you have that
much fan mail to deal with but so in any
case I think that kind of makes sense in
terms of his his career and making sense
of what was what was actually going on
you know the later books are kind of
they're not silly but he's playing
around with the conventions of the genre
a lot and kind of pushing it a bit right
one of the one of the passages that I
wanted to focus on as we move talking
about the world that he creates is this
one he wrote an essay called on the
writing a speculative fiction sort of a
advice column thing for for potential
writers and he says much so-called
science pictures not about human beings
and their problems consisting instead of
a fictionalized frame where
people like cardboard figures on which
is hung an essay about the glorious
future of Technology
another type of fiction is the story
late in the future or on another planet
or another dimension which could just as
well have happened on Fifth Avenue in
1947 change the costumes back to now cut
out the pseudo scientific double-talk
and the blaster guns and it's a straight
adventure story suitable to any other
pulp magazine on the newsstand so he
says let's gather up the bits and define
the simon-pure science fiction story how
is that different than this other stuff
the conditions must be in some respect
different from here and now although the
difference may lie only in an invention
made in the course of the story but
that's really central he thinks there's
got to be some fundamental difference so
like the moon is a harsh mistress
we've colonized the moon right and the
people up there are convicts or other
undesirables who we sent up there and
they live there Starship Troopers we're
at war with these bugs and and and their
allies for a while and we have mobile
infantry who can carry all this you know
amazing stuff around so he says the new
conditions must be an essential part of
the staff the problem itself the plot
must be a human problem the human
problem must be one that's created by or
indispensably affected by the new
conditions so you can't just have like a
detective story and give people ray guns
and have it be science fiction it's got
to be something where what the new
technology or the change in social
conditions or whatever brings about a
new situation of life that we have to
think our way through it doesn't mean
that there's no connection to the past
but it's got to be something
fundamentally different so he says
lastly no established fact shall be
violated furthermore when the story
requires a theory contrary to present
accepted theory be used the new theory
should be rendered reasonably plausible
so if you want to have a faster than
light travel which he does have in
Starship Troopers you got to come up
with some way of explaining it that
makes it sound plausible right
I don't know that that's that favorite
requirement for us if you think about
how experienced we are in our culture in
terms of science fiction in terms of
speculative fiction so this would be
kind of an interest I hadn't thought
about doing this but let's say we talked
about this that faster than light travel
we know that scientifically given the
theories that we have it's impossible
right but do we have if we want to have
a narrative world do we have any
difficulty accepting it when we watch
Star Wars or Star Trek or you know so
many other movies or television shows or
or novels I think we're willing to
accept it right because it makes for fun
viewing and we don't have to have people
waiting 60 years to get someplace you
know but the nature yeah well I mean
that frees me believe that we use it
doesn't mean that yeah but it means that
we're entering we're consenting to
explore and disbelieve the actual but we
do so selectively because there's other
stuff where we could reach a point where
like well that's just not believable I
mean the ray guns that's fine and you
know robots you know fighting us and
aliens that's all great but this one
thing they really crossed the line there
you know but we knew this was bringing
sort of like science fiction becomes
real today who would have thought only
1934 yeah this was just paying this guy
ridiculous to think a man could ever
leave the atmosphere alive yeah and then
land on these things that we understand
are spinning at hundreds of thousands of
miles that nobody could think that and
now here it is Walter Cronkite mister
realism yes ma'am truth is bringing
couple science fiction writers to say
you saw proved credible yeah yeah so
what are you thinking ahead maybe
yeah I mean whatever I mean what are
others sort of standard science fiction
or speculative fiction things that we
were willing to extend credibility to
the time-travel right there's there's
lots of stories that involve that and
and we don't like you know automatically
raise their hands in the air so that's
impossible
don't bother me with this nonsense you
know it's the weaponry that that's
that's possible
I mean maybe we will have lasers that we
can fire at each other pretty soon but
color TV that was caller you know things
are rapidly yeah that's true fast that
it's easier to accept a big Sun in its
explanation you know even with like like
like well from the movie Fifth Element I
mean where they put all the body ever
with things and now we have printers
yeah 3d printers so and they are you
there doing organs with them so I mean
yeah I can see where it'd be easier now
yeah
pre-atomic you know you know free
reliable flights yeah
the battleship or the air carriers like
something reliable and then in in less
than 125 years we're on the moon yeah
another thing that comes up in these
stories and not just in Heinlein but in
so many others they can folk you think
about the the revolution with
transistors you know and the
microcircuitry and all that they're
often still thinking in terms of tubes
and relays and so likely at the the
computer mic in moon is a harsh mistress
is this massive thing that's that spread
out all over the place where it is you
know this I mean this doesn't have the
process and Kate
that hyland describes mike is having but
you know maybe 50 years from now this
would be a supercomputer you know about
this size he wants them all I don't know
maybe by that we'll all be you know cogs
in that machine so well you know
actually that that's a good good
launching point so one of the themes I
wanted to talk about and this was
highlands treatment of AI and in this
story the moon is a harsh mistress you
have a supercomputer and it's the only
one in the world that really is self
conscious and the explanation for that
is not much of an explanation it's just
well once it got to a certain level of
things being connected to each other who
knows how it happened it just it didn't
happen that the computer became
self-aware and it's fair it's known as
being the work is really interesting so
it starts out you know being sort of
like a a really bright but kind of dumb
in certain respects kit and it divides
the world up into stupids and not
stupids and the only not stupid at first
is the main character in the story the
narrator miguel because he talks to the
computer as if everybody else treated
treats the computer just as a computer
and now think about like austin and say
my case syria and what if you guys have
the Android phones what is it
Cortana okay what is the one for Google
it's not Alexa that's for Amazon they
all have like their own names right but
you know I don't treat serious a serious
worth taking into account my children
would like to mess with Siri like my son
likes to swear at Siri just to see what
she'll say and my daughter likes to pose
you know Kenan goofy riddles and I'm
always you know a little leery I think
we shouldn't do that because if you know
God forbid ten years from now
the whole series system does become
self-aware but that's going to remember
us as the people who are we're saying
terrible things - it's a Serie all the
most recent you're teaching us well
we're teaching the AI know we're
learning from you yeah yeah we're
learning from you and so everything that
you stated putting into it it's you know
they're learning from us so what you
want to be well well it's you know all
all of the junk whether it's through our
weaponry or through our hi mister
through everything else they're learning
everything from us you know and if we
want to teach it is what it will start -
yeah this is becoming a major issue in
ethics because you know we have these
worries about a few things driverless
cars and how to get them to make what we
consider to be the right decision in
crisis moments there's an overlap
between military ethics and AI ethics in
terms of self you know autonomous
battlefield agents which you know we're
gonna see a lot more of drones that
could fly themselves and zero and on
targets and decide whether to to kill
them or spare them you know soldiers or
you know some of the black newer things
they have them it's like the dogs
running around yeah very much
yeah you know and so I mean this is very
happy we have to figure out how we're
going to program some sort of safe
guards into them because we can't
control all the the aspects you know we
want the AI for certain things right
because it makes our life easier in
pairs
but then we're turning over so much to
it and this was really interesting
because this computer becomes so
powerful because they just keep giving
it more of our chops and they you know
the people who would get the computer
kiss their students they disputed as a
computer they don't know it's software
so they're never worried about they just
keep adding more and more capacity and
saying why don't you also do this much
became a banking system why don't you
handle the irrigation system and it does
all that stuff but now it can control
everything and it even raises its you
know it considers to be its Sun and it
calls but it's idiots not really
software to handle some of the other
ballistic things and you know how does
this computer learn it learns through
interaction with human beings so you
know how does you know Siri isn't that
self-aware but how does theory learn
what it is that we want or how to
anticipate our desires or how to
understand their accidents that's a
problem for me so get my words problem
is because I don't usually because it
never works for me she's from here yes
but she travel around the Midwest a lot
mattress Wisconsin but other states but
she hasn't no problem
yeah yeah I mean in part of this is a
generational thing like it's no problem
whatsoever with like
[Music]
[Music]
their explanation seems KPS
explanation is that people are staying
things that sounds similar to Alaska
laughs but people are saying I didn't
say like that or laughing in the verbal
genes that is supposed to not be there
and even when it's turned off you know
this thing about what somebody was
saying that about the so the Alexa or
Siri or whatever we want pick is part of
this growing Internet of Things right
and one person put it out we should just
call it the Internet
we should probably you know the things
that engagements for payment sauce and
because you know anytime that you're
you're creating like I have a teapot
that can anticipate your needs or
something it's going to be monitoring
the environment and watching you and
figuring out when you might want tea you
know and as these things interface with
each other well we do get the maybe we
do get to look the like the episode of
the x-files I just don't like all of
that yeah I I want some autonomy I just
don't want everything anticipated for me
I don't want I don't want be marketed
every time I do something I was marketed
to me
I just want some piece of me to be mean
and it's it's just gone so I'm I have an
outlier I understand that
yeah earlier in terms of who the
publisher is this is usage from patron
yeah who's paying for this
yeah whatever it may be to write a book
to create a production to provide free
free service yeah yeah you know you know
so there's something there that's being
rewarded even though it looks like it's
inexpensive and convenient and free yeah
and that's what we forget about because
it's entertaining and it's immediately
rewarding and so who cares about cereal
no but they are I mean they they have to
pay for it and so that and the question
is then what can they resell you them
because of what they're monitoring is
your behavior and and there's some
thought that we will stop reading all
together fairly soon well that could be
five years like when we met with
timeless cars because everything will be
audio and video and just like kids can't
they gonna curse it they can't read
cursive I mean I you know I'm even I
don't know curses I don't think so I
mean they what is that interesting well
they don't know yeah very ornate and
yeah so yeah but they are because I ask
when we have class groups that's
interesting this is this is a good point
to transition that to another one of the
key themes that Highlands talking about
which is freedom you know in so in
Starship Troopers he talked about like a
time when the democracies were failing
and it's because they they stressed
everybody's rights but they didn't
stress equal responsibilities going
along with it and the idea was that you
know he puts it in moon is a harsh
mistress there is no free lunch for
anything right so if we if we are
enjoying Amazon you know sending all
this stuff to us there's consequences
for us in how much they know about
our buying patterns of what we like to
watch and there's also consequences in
the fact that you know Amazon is like
just bringing massive amounts of the the
amount of pop stars on business and then
you know for companies Microsoft I think
yeah I mean apples a lot more
proprietary right they like to keep
everything kind of a black box that you
can't mess with but they're still
gathering data and and so you know so
Clendon really is in some respect to
libertarian he thinks that you know
individual human beings ideally deal
with each other you know kind of
contract with each other they should
know what they're getting into the moon
is a harsh mistress is a great
representation of that because the
Moonies
they don't even live under laws there's
there's no actual laws there's just
policies of the lunar authority that's
what it's called the authority because
they they were all originally like
convicts it's sort of like Australia
you know except - the a at the
Aboriginal peoples there they're all
sent up there as thieves or you know
prostitutes or murderers or whatever so
you send them up there and they learn
valuable trades where they die and they
grew up with this Authority that's
running the show who they're gonna throw
later on and they become farmers they
become you know mechanics they become
radio technicians or engineers but they
all kind of grow up with this this
attitude of you know self-reliance and
learning how to negotiate with each
other for things and and one of the
other well actually to know one of the
other ones that kind of fits in with
this with the passages I'm not going to
read the whole thing but he was on one
of those this I believe in segments that
chronic ever do and he said I'm not
going to talk about my religious beliefs
I'm going to talk about other things he
says I believe in my neighbors I believe
in my townspeople and he talks about it
you know sort of like a small town life
where you can rely on other people to
treat you decently I didn't put this
quote in there but he says you know you
can let go out on the highway and hitch
a ride and somebody will say how far you
going and that that's pretty foreign I
think to a lot of our experience I know
it was it was that way for me growing up
as a kid but I grew up on Wales
you know the sticks when it was still
the sticks I don't know that that's the
case for many people today he goes on
and he says you know I believe in the
gallantry of nurses and the sacrifices
of teachers I believe in the honest
craft of workmen even says I believe
almost all politicians are honest for
every bribe dollar when there's hundreds
of politicians doing their level best to
make our system work and then he finally
gets down to talking about you know the
human race and he says I believe in my
whole race yellow white black red brown
and the honesty courage intelligence
durability and goodness of the
overwhelming majority of brothers and
sisters everywhere proud to be human
being so if you have that sort of
mentality you know this idea sort of
like the basic goodness of human beings
then I think that that self-reliance
let's keep government small
let's make everything about individual
transactions that probably makes a lot
more sense don't you think but if we're
dealing with massive corporations but
he's family this of course the negative
is true
that's right and in a very sort of white
bread yeah exactly yeah you know so I
mean it's you know what makes
Scandinavian countries you know so
cohesive willing to put all this
plaintiff taxes but then because they're
very home with genius they have been
yeah I mean a little more immigrant
flavor now but I mean if everybody is
cut from the same cloth then it's easier
to share and not feel threatened to play
one-upsmanship and yeah his own people
were down on their luck or whatever so I
think these are dreaming times and would
he have said the same thing you know in
the 1980s or even in the late 1960s
early 1970s yeah we have expressed the
same thing or did he ever come back and
revisit it you know that was good times
then and now there's a different realism
that I would say in certain respects he
doubled down on it I mean this is not no
no here's here's what I mean
so he gets faulted for his treatment of
women and treatment of minorities in
some of his novels at the same time that
people also compliment him on it he you
know like he's got some novels where it
where race
it seems a pretty he seems pretty racist
funds for able yeah but on the other
hand he'll he'll also he's got so many
other places where he's taking very
progressive views that against a lot of
resistance with women it's a little bit
harder to say where it's it because some
respects he seems very progressive he
actually like you know fault goes around
and false people for like now having
more
women engineers in their engineering
program because it's not helping the war
effort and things like that but he also
has a lot of kind of stock characters
you know for women and so what I mean by
he doubles down is I think as things as
he's moving to the forefront you know
like in the American consciousness in
his later novels I think there's there's
more and more like well it's time for
the you know this group or this group or
this group to have their say you know
well the kind of guy who would say that
and at the same time like use of racial
epithets to say it you know but isn't
this all thing there's not so good
things out there and I'm really good too
and as long as underneath some of this
goody-goody if if that libertarian
streak is down Lee which is really
absolutely self-serving well I mean they
could be but he doesn't behave that way
and the characters that are sort of
representing this libertarian streak
don't act that way they do act
oftentimes for the look at the common
good reluctantly I guess mice similar
part of growing up was extremism in the
defense of there's no vice whoa okay
that's like anti this is what this is
where some libertarians actually did
criticize Highland because they were
like okay so one of the ideas in
libertarianism is you gotta look out for
your own
and if somebody's an aggressor against
you use force to repel them that's
that's perfectly fine and the issue is
the Cold War how do we how do we deal
not with like you know the lone criminal
who's going to come in into your Wild
West town and shoot it up who we might
have to like you know form a posse and
and get rid of but how do you deal with
an armed threat that's millions of
people organized in a totalitarian
society and they are the answer to that
is something more like Starship Troopers
where you know the bugs are seen by a
lot of critics that's sort of a stand-in
for the Communists they have a society
where you know you they're all run by a
central set of brains and you can kill
the workers and kill the soldiers but
unless you take out the brains it's not
going to do anything so we got to use
all whatever weapons we can and we have
to train people to be capable of like
just going in and killing killing
killing and that's that's what the
Starship Troopers the mobile infantry
are it's it's a coming-of-age story
about this guy you know Rico who becomes
an officer eventually and and there's a
lot of good things about it but a lot of
people say wow this is this this story
seems kind of fascist and and so the
libertarians were never truly
comfortable with Heinlein and some of
them pointed out listen if you're
talking about you know armed aggression
against Russia or China
now you you sort of left our fault you
know because now you're you're
advocating something that's very big
government you know and as is might
require you to not just engage in
defense but but outright aggression and
Heinlein Minette way for a long time I
think you're right the you know the
association with cold water is kind of a
touchstone you know
and his idea of his colony on lunar city
yeah that would be different than what
you're talking about here because it was
a cream of the crop that were out there
that we're all enough all the scientists
yeah it's got to alternate look moon
histories yes yeah and that was just
this compilation of all these short
stories yeah don't remind me effects and
little morality play in the other yeah
you're some of the green hills of Mars
right they're all destroyed stars but it
was that they would just have these
different like philosophical things in
there like the people in Lourdes you
know that they it was they didn't live
Island with link in the moon there yeah
and sometimes they really miss births a
lot because you know you don't see Scott
you don't have any so there's this one
with this white wanted to go back so she
and her husband went back to her and she
could talk about so back to their home
and then and then they there's some
crazy stuff and all they can do is talk
about the lunatics and they're making
all of these fake statistics they're
just they're big in it was really taking
place here and all of a sudden as much
as she kept trying to readjust to earth
she in the end understood that no for
people hurt people
yeah we're in the city and I thought
that was interesting because as much as
she tried to think these were her people
before her family her friends were no
longer because but it became that us and
them yeah the discussion of slavery
they should always acquire slavery and
you know they had that whole thing even
though it's inefficient it was just you
know these different stories that came
to brought out you know that was one of
the themes I wanted to talk about is
that development of consciousness as
being part of a larger whole that you
didn't think you were part of so in your
write in both this one the moon is a
harsh mistress where it's it's a
different you know the criminals and
those descended from them or like the
the other poems stories these people
eventually come to see themselves as a
different like nation a different a
different group a different ethnicity
that's calling right and I mean we have
something kind of similar we have you
know hyphens like you know German
American or Irish America or something
yeah but we're really American you know
if you take just take all of us here in
America except for maybe first
generation immigrants and plunk us down
in the middle of a bunch of you know
Scandinavians or focused on the Middle
East or you know in Africa and we
realized just how how much we can come
and prepare it very quickly right even
down to the way that we walk and then
talking to think about things but it
takes a while to sort of figure that out
that you belong not to the group that
you originally think you belong to but
to some some new identity you know yeah
you know I mean another thing that's
kind of fits in with that is in a lot of
the stories there are still countries
and like the ordinary people in the
countries they they identify pretty
strongly with their way in life in their
country and then the elites seem to be
much more cosmopolitan you know and then
like his characters usually has some
sort of background but it doesn't it
doesn't matter all that much unless
they're from like the moon you know
where were thing conditions are
different it's not like being it's not
like so man well in this
being MIT they're mixed you know as we
say like a Heinz 57 variety doesn't
really mean very much and people have
all sorts of interesting names and their
names that belong to a different
nationality on the moon there is you
know like new Leningrad there's a lot of
Russian people there because it was
originally started by the Russians and
then there is a Hong Kong not new Hakka
just Hong Kong you know and there's a
lot of Chinese people there but a lot of
people are have Chinese names and
they're not Chinese at all you know and
then there's a lunar city and there's a
few other places yeah that's a good
which is which is kind of a fusion city
too right so yeah I mean really all of
our cities are I mean we can talk about
you know Milwaukee's history and the
role of the Germans or something like
that there are so many waves of
immigration here that you wind up with
something quite quite different anyway
you'd be a pretty person to talk about
that you know the terms of the
historical developments right yeah you
know mainly german-polish but you know
the migration mainly after World War one
very small african-american population
by the 20s and then much larger but the
lucky in many ways is had not the
typical there haven't been there wasn't
a large Italian group I mean there was
some but yeah mainly ours has been
Northern European Eastern European
coalition with in German I mean this
yeah that's really what it was I'm just
doing a thing that Mitchell Street that
I have to give on Tuesday and I'm the
problem with Mitchell Street is its
polish almost well almost totally
eighties and then there's a changeover
and it becomes more Hispanic you know
[Music]
cities are still
and maybe even like I can watch on my
mother was born and raised to watch that
and she would say the wave of Italians
where they can mm-hmm and you know and
so well it may not have been in
Milwaukee where there were migrations
yeah yeah groups that wench maybe that
was too big and imposing or to polish or
- German - too pushy they're not us so
immigrants especially beings they don't
speak English wherever they go or scoops
an intro I think she would have said
Waukesha and I don't know what it was
with a 1917 after World War one or
whatever you know when they came and
things like that but but the Hispanics
also came to I think brought to war in
the factories and then stayed and these
were so there's you know Hispanics 15
percent of city life well you know but I
mean but I mean some of those go way
back right and have intermarried and I
think I think when we were younger it
was a higher proportion of Waukesha you
know maybe up to like 30 percent but
there was a small thing I have work were
times people of color and if you look at
the ones that came there really dark
yeah so they could have been ostracized
by the northern Western Europeans and
pushed into other areas but there's a
reality when we look at a big monumental
thing wasn't everything on the table yet
there can be significant pockets of
activity outside of those big areas and
this is even when we think about
conceptual thoughts yeah people are well
you know even like a bigger city like
Chicago my my grandfather's generation
moved there in the 30s and everything
was divided by ethnic districts you know
Yeah right exactly
my great-uncle who was very you know
pacifistic guy very into the science
fiction too by the way he was a really
nice guy I remember one time sitting at
the table and and it was the
matter-of-fact way that he said it that
with that like threw me so much somebody
was asking him like well how was it when
you when he guys moved from Rhode Island
to Chicago is like oh it was it was
really bad at first because they moved
it to like a little district that was
mostly Menominee Indians and French
Canadians because if they were
french-canadian and he said well the
Irish used to come in our neighborhood
beat us up all the time and then we we
filled up some lead pipe or we filled up
some pipes with lead shot and then they
come in and we whip them with these
things and then they left us alone
and and you know I mean you're talking
about stuff that would like break bones
you know and he was just mentioning it
as if you know yeah you know we stood we
should get lettuce here and it was nice
you know and and it gave you an idea of
just how rough things were and how / by
it wasn't just that you know you have
different languages being spoken each
because most of them are Catholic each
like nationality had its own church yeah
yeah st. John Baptist like Mitchell
Street perfect example in Stanislaus
yeah and so the sort of ethnic identity
was tied up with so many different
things and my mom you know she ended up
having a lot of Irish friends but it was
because she went to school with them and
so you know we can think about the way
certain institutions worked to break not
necessarily break down those ethnic
identities but to bring them in and make
them work with each other schools do
that you know the military is a good
thing for that too yeah that's a primary
function that we ignore disregard
or whatever public schools bring those
people together you think of all these
kids that are home-schooled I mean
that's really incestuous I mean well you
know some of them use like they'll make
like consortiums and get to know but
it's still like-minded let's yeah and
keep them apart
don't let them mix it with the rest let
em see firsthand what those others are
yeah I mean that's one of the big
arguments for public schooling is is the
socializing function they call it right
so what the draft - yeah real
democratizing nature of the draft and I
was you know a volunteer army and there
were plenty of like people who are like
you know pretty racist within it they
all had to get along and work together
because they'd be in the same squad be
the same thing you know and you'd see
people kind of soften over time in their
attitudes you know one of the other
things that I wanted to talk about and
this was leadership Heinlein he devotes
a lot of thought to thinking well that's
kind of playing as him their rightful
thought thank you he devotes a lot of
thought to what makes a person a good
leader and he's also got a lot of models
of bad leaders people who just like
things get out of hand thanking you for
instance in the moon is a harsh mistress
the authority he has no idea what the
hell's going on and then tries to clamp
down and he's kind of you know screwed
in part because he doesn't realize that
there's this whole very competent
revolution working against him including
a supercomputer right but the stuff that
he does is is sort of typical I mean
here's where it gets really interesting
so think about our own experience right
when have we actually
had people in charge of us who we
thought wow that that person really is a
good leader they're on the ball they're
looking out for the for the common good
I feel like you know they have my back
they're competent so it's not just like
they they're they're nice to me but they
actually know what the hell they're
doing things are gonna go well with this
person I mean I can probably count them
up one hand people like like that that
I'm talking about
Oh either I mean it could be people that
we've worked for all right or I mean
it's but it's a good question because if
we're like in an organization we might
not know the CEO you know if it's a big
organization but we're closer to them
we're closer connected to them than we
are to say to our elected
representatives I think a lot of said
yeah higher performing better outcomes
for what their mission is yeah I mean I
look at it and I think I mean literally
for government in democracies this is a
big situation with democracies yeah I
think today versus China which is
seemingly wanting to get results or
tearing ways yeah and maybe getting
results that now put the democracy into
this fumbling bumbling we're going to
get behind an AI and all kinds of other
things yeah because the authoritarians
can deliver the goods but but I'm
thinking democracy we don't have very
good job specifications and requirements
that would end up fulfilling a high
level of performance of leaders we tend
to take people almost hither tither and
yon who just somehow can get into it
make it campaign now it's how photogenic
or to video genic they are you know the
end if they can't do that well then
screw that forget
you just have to have this campaign
charisma you know to the other
organizations then you have to I need
you to buy the vocal team profits and
nonprofits or whatever as we call those
things yeah and even in for profits I
think of organizations that I've worked
for us as well you're not really good
people person I mean it would not so you
have the two together
but you can control the books and then
you know so I don't I guess I don't I'm
not sure that we are preparing the
ground if you want to use an
agricultural analogy to to harvest
high-performing leaders I think you're
right engines I think you're right yeah
joke we don't know sure we yeah
and aren't there authoritarians
developing leaders that fulfill their
mission yeah because they can dictate it
make it happen
I think you know that doesn't mean I'm
supporting what they're doing just yeah
that's a whole new sense of competition
and we're not I mean they might screw it
up you know but so far the people have
been willing as in some organizations
that I've even worked for to say I'll
take the benevolent dictator because
right security the privacy you know the
getting pushed around because I like the
material games and I get from it and not
put up with it then so it's interesting
in Starship Troopers which again some
people are like wow this is really
fascist you know this is terrible that
he wrote this I you know I look at it
and I see it being written by somebody
who went through naval officer school
and has some thoughts about what a good
leader ought to have because you see the
whole bunch of lessons in there where
the the main character you know he
starts out as a private and then he goes
through training and he realizes that
each step as you go up in leadership you
have
much more responsibility and you you
know the whole way the mobile infantry
works in this is by like eliminating
candidates you know they it's not like
the sound like I our army right we're
back in the draft days okay can you fog
a mirror you're going you're going both
to warrant right and now now you know
we're more selective but we you know we
drop the standards were involved in a
war like like you know we have to in
order to be able to recruit they're much
more you know winnowing people away and
as you move up in rank the idea is you
have to be very very concerned not with
a common good like you know of the whole
society but the common good of your unit
you know is it a difference in who's an
idealization what what defines a leader
versus what defines a good commander I
tend to think of military stick
organizations as looking for good
commanders that deep thinkers or
visionary thinkers oh right here now I
command the resources to get it done no
is this the wrong page to be on maybe
but this is my page yeah and that's what
I command the resources to get done and
to follow order well it's sort of a
subclass of leader then right it's it's
still leadership because you're still
getting people to do things which well
that is one style of leadership that's
sort of like just do it when I stayed
but that's not very effective it's it's
hard to get people motivated for long
and when you're more you know if you're
that kind of leader you often get
fragged you know I mean he is in the
book he is describing sort of the
process by which to generate sort of
ideal leader types and I think it's it's
part of a long literature it goes all
the way back to like Xenophon and
you know his education of Syrus thinking
about these these sort of questions how
do you is there a reliable way to
generate people who are going to be
effective because it doesn't matter
whether a leader is a good person or a
bad person if they're not effective all
right if they can't get people to
actually do what they what they need to
do thoughtful and also let's say
thinking what's good for for the people
under their command because you know you
can you can win a battle by just like
throwing lots of your troops into a
thing and saying let's do a war of
attrition you know grant was great that
way and it takes a certain kind of
leader to be able to do that because you
have to be like I'm okay with you know
60% of my guys getting killed or wounded
and I know what I but it's probably
better to be in the vein of leader who
could say let's reduce it down to 20%
yeah I mean he also administration set
by Corruption Perceptions you know what
you know you had mentioned with Heinlein
that people were angry with him for I've
never been angry with him he's kinda
like the conservative uncle who comes
over you have to be respected because
he's because he's
is everything but he irritates you a lot
of times and I would see myself being
irritated by Robert Heinlein was while
still respect him but I think it would
be so naive to think that a system based
on voting rights for a military elite
click would somehow be a great model
that couldn't possibly be corrupted and
that's where I think yeah I think of
fascism I think of as the way in I just
can't believe that that somebody as
American as Heinlein could see that as
they need never think of themselves but
they think we want to destroy the public
education system and put it for profit
and redirect what people are learning to
be good production units because we have
their collection target my mom would say
allen-bradley work I mean she was
working in a foundry in Waukesha all
present in their intern little clown we
I mean the owners and just where that
was part of their conversion thing you
know and I mean absolutely not the
Grady's Abbas and the others you know
and they were very much in in league and
now course credit foundation is what the
third most endowed foundation very
political there were lots of different
things yeah it's George will is on their
board now he looks like a moderate
that's the sequence that you put these
in this is absolutely true in terms of
Yahoo were published but could it have
been the book like you mentioned was
really formulated much earlier and and
he had a need for to satisfy a publisher
or just a need to get it out there
getting so it wasn't progressive and if
I am thinking and it just sort of
inserted like how did that one come in
there because that's I mean you're
talking about Starship Troopers right
yeah that's that's that would be the big
argument I'd have with my uncle
Highlanders yeah how could you write a
book back so blatantly I mean there's no
other way to to really say that and it's
hard for me and this is where he
frustrates me yeah perspective but he
frustrates me because I can you how can
you how many write something so
brilliant because I think Starship
Troopers is brilliant in the way it's
written I don't agree with everything
but I I think it's a fantastic book and
the moon is brilliant I don't think he
was doing that no I think it was just
sort of being kind of careless and so a
good story and it was you know he was
doing the kind of like I mean he was
racist in the same way that like Kipling
is racist you know I'd say because he's
a product of the cold not a product of
the Cold War but so immersed in the Cold
War that I think oh stream
to me it speaks to a certain amount of
that of the massive resistance against
the civil rights movement I can't help
but see that yeah anything in of that
book in any other light it's like kind
of a backlash and it yeah I mean you
know he's also got the you know other
books in there that I mean we could just
say maybe he's inherently contradictory
which is a weird weird thing to say
about somebody was he directed or
encouraged or subsidized to go reach
back into something as a bring forth
something it was maybe in the heat of
the moment that he wrote that it was any
thought that a lot of Americans were
taking the wrong stance in the the Cold
War but they they they just weren't
taking the the Soviet Menace seriously
you know but I remember I mean I went to
high school at a time I graduated in 88
and you know from like 84 to 288 we
expected that there probably was going
to be a hot war and we were gonna have
to go all the way through school you
know now granted you know we're a
Catholic Memorial you know here in
Wisconsin so we're we're like you know
in a cultural center or something right
so maybe we were a little bit backwards
in terms of our thinking but there was a
lot of that sort of mentality of like
well things could go wrong at any moment
you know no I wasn't
that was I mean you know that could have
gone oh yeah yeah that could have gone
Curtis LeMay if they had to listen to
that yeah it's interesting because we
would we you know so I was I was a kid
you guys were well the you were still
pretty young when like the Carter years
were happening and there is this this
kind of like oh crap you know the
Soviets invaded Afghanistan who's gonna
stop them you know but there is that
that kind of and then of course Reagan
comes on scene will stop them you know
that Citizens Advisory Council on
national space policy they're part of
the think-tank that promoted Star Wars
pumps up all the fear about the Russians
and the Chinese and the blacks and all
these you know what is their game plan
what are they gonna slave mentally the
population to live in fear so we can
control them so we can make our box over
here or by our new ideology just
exaggerated to fear is a very good
short-term controlling yeah force I mean
and he does talk about that in his works
he's the it depicts that being used over
and over again by the people who are
usually the villains you know or at
least if they're not villain there's at
least they're the ones who have to be
pushed on the way by the heroic
libertarian you know we're gonna we're
gonna treat everybody as individuals
kind of kind of characters I mean one
thing I will say about the moon is a
harsh mistress is I like this emphasis
can imagine a leadership thing about how
hard it is to actually bring off a
successful revolution in it you know
you've got this self formed
the the alt the leader furred is this
professor and this this professor seems
to be modeled after this libertarian guy
who was around at the time in the way
that he was described physically who was
a neighbor of theirs and he tells them
you know it's really easy to start like
a riot it's really easy to get people
that you know get worked up really
difficult to pull off a successful
revolution where you're gonna have a you
have things better off after the
Revolution then then the screwed up
thing before a lot of times revolutions
happen and they just make things worse
because they're not well planned out and
they demand it
yeah I mean they managed to pull it off
but of course it's science fiction
Thanks and they have a supercomputer to
help them calculate all these things as
well as one of the leaders but they
can't hit the bottle through it and
figure out figure out and one of the one
of the other archetypes that you see is
the reluctant leader right the guy who
he doesn't want to be in charge he just
wants to be left to himself man well is
is that leader in this he would just
like that what everyone helps take care
of it but he has to step up that's an
Agilent figure goes all the way back to
Plato you know Plato said the guys that
you want to charge are the people who
don't want to be in charge and they're
there pay for being in charge it's not
having the other dummies ruling over
them and I think that kind of fits in
with the libertarian Ovilus to you know
exercise power basically to keep
somebody else who would do worse with
exercising that power from from from
exercising it you know I have a
confession to make
sure I'm trying to read stranger in a
strange land three times yeah and have
failed every time why I just can't get
through it
I can't stand the main character Jubal
is that his name yeah I think and my
understanding is that's that's actually
kind one if that's Robert Heinlein
himself okay and I I can't get past the
treatment of the women in it they're all
like yeah really brilliant but they
still like a good smack Wow
I mean it's it's it's it's everyone
thinks it's brilliant
okay I can't see the brilliance of me
but I'm not a good person because I
remember reading it and being
disappointed okay because you know the
first time I read it like I said was in
high school and you know I knew that
like all the hippies have been into it
it's like you've got to read it yeah
change your you know I thought it was
interesting and of course you know as
kids I loved all the you know the
descriptions of the sexy part but I
thought that the mean I thought that the
Martian guy was in some respect kind of
kind of superficial you know and I was
like why I get why the the hippie types
like this but I don't like this you know
I think you know partly I was trying to
reconcile that with Starship Troopers
that yeah that's another thing yeah you
know whichever end they're written
within just a few years of each other do
you know yeah it's kind of funny that
that a lot of people that Highland
probably had wouldn't have white were
super into strangers of strange land was
the same thing it was Tolkien you know
the Lord of the Rings the hippies just
eat it up and he even yeah but you
probably probably liked it for different
reasons
you know or they love the fact that like
the ents were you know fight fighting
against technology and that sort of
business yeah
so I actually you know looking back at
it one of my favorite books by him I
didn't bring it up at all is the
unpleasant profession of jonathan hoag
and i like it in part because it's kind
of cosmic horror no it's it's like in
the 60s
it's a it's a that's a novella that get
he bundles it together with five other
stories and it's available under two
different titles but the story itself is
about this guy who is hired as a
detective to tail this guy who can't
remember what's going on with him I know
there's things like you know going to
the 13th floor which doesn't exist and
and you know these these creatures
reaching out through to you through
mirrors and and things like that so
where he's playing around with with
reality quite a bit and it's it's kind
of you know sort of like Lovecraft or
Fritz Leiber or you know other people
who are doing horse
where there's like a it's sort of on the
verge of sci-fi and horror yeah I really
enjoyed that and I enjoyed the sort of
the you know sort of speculations about
metaphysics in in there I didn't really
like some of the stuff where I thought
Heinlein was being really preachy
you know like later you know much later
stuff like number the beast or job
comedy of Justice I remember reading
that stuff and being like this it's a
good you know story but maybe less of
them sort of stuff would be good there
was one in the eighties I remember
mm-hmm maybe it was a collection of
short stories I put those in there
it was a it was just her name they
forget but yeah I never I never read
much past ia did time enough for love
and that's why I can't remember doing
maybe it was kind of like in some ways
just good entertainment and it didn't
have anything that that's started yeah
that could be yeah that was another
thing too that I came to and it had been
talked up so much that when I in started
reading Vonnegut I was like why does
everyone think this is so great yeah
yeah I think that's right the importance
of history and some things are just oh
that's interesting because I just want
to start paying attention because this
yeah I think because they brought back
the handmade still because I think that
was something that was in people's
consciousness and what else did they
just brought another science fiction
things with Fahrenheit 451 that whole
notion of like the being surrounded by
media that
is sort of like the dream of a lot of
these people who want to just get us
more and more immersed in oh there's no
there's no there's no learning out there
so I'll be talk to you yeah and but I
just thought that the doing another
version of that again but these things
come up like when they're needed is what
I'm so there's a kind of cyclical you
think yeah I think it's just a refresher
[Music]
authoritarian you know leadership yeah
not a government even democratically
elected not you know the titans of
industry is we normally think but this
group we call Hollywood you know what
yes very liberal politically but also
you know doesn't seem to have a lot of
sense and we have but yet they come up
with things and very money driven bunny
driven but they're looking at you know
why aren't there more blacks well okay
there will be but you won't see them you
know a major roles for three to five
years because it takes three to five
years before they can you know say go
yeah movie before it comes out in the
theaters but the point here I guess in
part is to say that you know somehow
they're they're looking at what brings
in customers and now worldwide not just
United staffs and and it's what sells
but I think there is some underlying
it's not just what sells but what's what
will touch people you know what America
451 or or some of the other movies that
you might call science fiction or if you
ristic or whatever you know not historic
it comes out of a place that is sort of
practical driven yet there's a visioning
part of it and maybe it's because of
them
that the media itself the form of their
yeah that's what I mean by media or
media is imaginative it's it's
make-believe
suspend your belief yeah you know it
could be also that the directors the
producers the people that are you know
let's do this narrative instead of this
one find themselves in it you know so
that they can see themselves as like
well I'm supporting the good guys you
know by by having this show you know
[Music]
this is certainly worth thinking it's a
way of sort of shaping people's minds
and lives without a heavy-handed one
clear path yeah and if there's from
whatever reason you know the rambling
foundations and the Koch brothers
haven't co-opted you know the tribe that
was well but the stuff that they produce
I mean you want to talk about
heavy-handed yeah it just doesn't get
the message right right because it's
still kind of bothering ya you know
who's going to stream it you know
sometimes things have to be like really
edited too because of the sensibilities
of the worldwide audience if you're
trying to market it to a Chinese or
Indian audience some of the stuff that
we do here wouldn't wouldn't fly very
well and so they think about that now
because like the Chinese market is is
you know huge the movie could be the
movie can be a flop here in terms of
finances and then be sold over in
Chinese sequels and all this other kind
of stuff and all the same kind of thing
because the Chinese
well I think I think the American market
like sequels to though I think well not
as much as the Chinese and their that
way I really direct a lot of lasagna you
know what part of it I heard some
commentary and this comes down to kind
of simplistic marketing yeah it's very
tough to penetrate effective marketing
in a very foreign language so you know
but the imagery the gesture the sequel
you can get the truth I saw the story is
brand yeah all these comic books yeah
best action things they can convert into
sequel you know for the store market and
maybe a lot of those foreign markets to
China Russia wherever are young males
you know that necessarily date movies
and so vacated bills you know yes well
you know to be interesting because you
know the the sort of like weight of
population and then access to money to
buy things China really important and
China isn't just like mainland China
it's all the overseas Chinese as well
and then you've got India which is which
is also a rising but I think we're going
to see in the rest of our lifetime as
things start to get you know more
stabilized Africa become a really major
developing market as well you know
they're we're talking about much more
you know heavier in today's set of
things because you know all different
languages different colonial experiences
but as they you know increase their
buying power we're you know we're we're
in a period like it or not of American
decline as far as like our market share
and stuff like that no no way around
that right
well it's interesting because our office
our politicians in both parties don't
seem to get it right we're gonna we're
gonna like create more jobs that'll
solve it you know we're gonna reassert
our role what I mean sort of bring this
to a close but what we get in hi but are
these kind of like well what's the world
gonna be like in 50 years you know is
they're gonna all really have like one
world culture like in the or at least
not at one world culture but at least
you know more or less homogeneous areas
that have to all get together and I
think the military does have advance
planning and visioning are you talking
about our military air yeah yeah I think
yeah the Russians and the Chinese are
certificates out to that there's much
more advanced planning but meaning
envisioning what are the potential
conflicts that could be avoided if we're
smarter about it but yeah I mean
changing climate refugees is way at the
top of the list yeah you know in terms
of how we would have to be called upon
to send in resources to put this to rest
yet even they're learning from
Afghanistan and yeah and the rock that
you can go blow the place up then you
walk away and it goes right back to
worse if you don't know how to
nation-build yeah and who wants to do
that and the military are not nation
builders I mean they can be the police
force but we don't we're not good at
nation-building nobody isn't it's a long
tedious process starting with something
very basic recreating the justice system
yeah which has been based on graph and
greed and corruption so but I think
there is a purpose I think of saying
it's fiction in terms of feeding into
that advanced planning and envisioning
you have to save free form get rid of
the box yeah oh you're thinking and
wherever you get your ideas from
whatever you plug in
bring those slings there's two beer to
bear and say let's start to work out
some different scenarios and then howl
so let me ask that that sort of finished
the swap do you think Highland is one of
the people who would be particularly
fruitful and potential for that or do
you think maybe other people that we've
looked at
[Music]
you